過去形のハシドゥ
とコマンド形のクル
は大丈夫です
が、その言葉では実際に
はアクセントがないので、
ヤメテで
もヤメテでも
ないので、多かれ少なかれフラットな
ので、何を先に進めます
か ええと、それは私がストリーミングに使用するミキサーですえ
えと、ええと
、それの名前は何ですか？それはかなり面白いですええと、それの名前は何ですか？なぜあなたは種間レビューアのために新しいダブを作ろうとしているのですか？
過去形の声かなりかっこいいおもちゃええととにかく
動詞に戻りましょうトラックから外れる前にそれをオフ
にしてください
さまざまな種類
の動詞に
、nomuとhanasuのif形式と
ミキサーの名前はどうですか？
ミキサーの名前dougan私は
あなたがそれに興味がなかったと思いましたああ
私はこの甥を持っています甥ええこれは
ええと 彼がしたい甥
あなたの
甥がストリーミングに参加したい場合は、彼が
良い声を出すことができるかどうかではなく、彼が使用しているマイクやカメラについてもっと心配する必要があります
彼はカメラとマイクをすでに持っています
ええ、彼は実際に
いくつかのマイクをストリーミングしていますか？
ええと、確かにそれは確かに
sm777ジョギングでしたなぜあなたは声を変えるミキサーを手に入れようとしているのですか
ストリーミングですが、
たまたま派手なカメラ
と400 xlrマイクがあり
ますが、そもそも動作するにはミキサーが必要です。
ミックスが1つか2つあると言うのを忘れていました。